you know where are we in the world of
media right now we're in a a tectonic
shift and everything's changing really
really rapidly I think of its role as
being this mirror that reflects us back
to us and helps tell us who we are and
who we're capable of and that's where my
frustration is greatest because I think
we're getting a very narrow
reflection of ourselves back to
ourselves and what these tools are
capable of is beautiful but what we're
actually using them for is a vast subset
of that beauty and so we get like ad
driven monetization of stuff we get a
hyper focus on conflict and Discord
versus collaboration and creativity and
I think we become what we see so there's
a lot of responsibility in the media
game and technology is
just adding fuel to an already raging
fire in terms of like possibility
confusion and sometimes uh chaos